Why is this an important application class to consider? Well,
obviously the Internet has just opened up so many different opportunities for
applications. That means, not only more applications but more customers,
heavier load, increasing demand on the resources. Hence,
performance and resource consumptions considerations, nonfunctional constraints.
Also, the hardware resources themselves have become more specialized.
Think about ATM machines or card readers at gas stations, or
mobile phones, or square card readers.
Just all kinds of devices that have their own peculiarities.
Also we've seen increasingly powerful applications, okay, that involve
integrations of existing components, and sometimes even negotiation among them.